pop
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
la voilà la balle à la suze attia vive
voix la saison le mauvais temps n'a pas
retardé 13
voilà ma noisy et entendu si vous saviez
comme ça me fait plaisir de voir ma
saison c'est moi qui lui il ya dix ans
nous étions deux amis inséparables je
sais mais les années vous poussez voilà
que ma saison a dépassé 20 ans depuis
qu'elle est partie dans ce collège
anglais jonathan toutes deux fois l'an
au campo noël des anneaux ava ava
mais c'est un peu ma petite fille à la
fin c'est la même histoire depuis deux
mois que celui-ci quand on travaille
depuis 15 ans dans une maison fini par
croire qu'on ne lui souhaite que les
enfants sont elles vous vous verrez si
vous croyez que je pense et ma vie à
faire la boniche c'est un métier qui ne
vous plaît pas beaucoup alors pourquoi
le faite vous faut bien vu vous êtes
tombé dans une bonne maison ici où
trouver à de mon temps je veux dire du
temps où ils ont été là c'était plus que
ça évidemment de méras enfin nous allons
passer de merveilleuses fêtes de noël la
veillée aux chandelles
qu'est-ce qu'on l'ait qu'on fasse
d'autre est à 5 km du village et que de
la neige qui est tombée cette nuit quand
même pas aller au bal quel dimanche
même pas la télévision la télévision va
ne perdez rien ça fait mal aux yeux
c'est le déjeuner de monsieur vous avez
monté non c'est de la petite vous avais
avertis monsieur que la voiture vient
d'arriver
madame est allé chercher suzon à la gare
monsieur mabillon ne pas réveiller ne
pas réveiller quand sa fille arrive pour
les fêtes de noël portait depuis son
petit déjeuner est averti ces mamies
mademoiselle auguste bon rassurez vous
mademoiselle augustine est certainement
déjà au tour 3 ça prend la peine qu'elle
écoute aux portes
ne soyez pas aussi insolente je n'aime
pas vos réflexions et moi sommes pas les
leçons de morale parce que la morale
cette fille là on fera jamais rien
mais le jdle et les tarifs et madame
votre petite fille arrive regardez le
bouchât sera comme ils viennent
ça vous fait plaisir mais aussi à vous
êtes gentil en quoi moi mais tout le
monde et en tue avec vous ici
certainement je suis très heureuse que
mon genre d'homme est accueilli avec sa
fille augustine
mais vous savez nous ne sommes quand
même pas si nous la voilà les scanner
oculi n'ont pas envoyé le corps retour
segel un maigre au channel on trouve
toujours aussi content je fais mon
régime du terme appstore bras bien sûr
insuffisant avec la permission de madame
elle est magnifique ce soit
une heure
jeune fille a marqué tout à fait ton
avis mamie à marier très vite tempère va
être redevenu qui se fait tendre russie
pour toi vite avertit wantzenau il
aurait donné ordre qu on ne réveille pas
comment une peur des 110 on sait il a dû
travailler dans sa chambre et y être et
à wade doit être fatigué tuent à la
tâche ils se tuent à la tâche
il a dû lire toute la nuit sans doute
comme on s'en doute
ils font chambre à part c'est angleterre
quand wayne the winter et sting with
many people c'est l'anglais tous ces
mois là anglais tout ce que c'est c'est
good bye peps qui épicent mis comme moi
qui suis dit tu as déjà dit keith mis à
un anglais va bien sûr à la libération
au premier que j'ai fait pour ma part
des chewing-gums et je raconte ma vie
j'ai mon petit déjeuner c'est bon de se
retrouver chez soi
ma chère vieille maison pas et va tâcher
vieille maison un grand coup de peinture
lui ferait pas de mal enfin elle plaît à
tempère ainsi alors tiens voici louise
notre nouvelle femme de chambre bonjour
unique façon mademoiselle j'espère qu'on
va pas à la sphère renvoya la bon malgré
un temps un peu vantard en passant dans
la forêt tout à l'heure avant ça c'est
tomber la nage des arbres quelle
solitude
on se serait cru en plein ciel en place
hier en plein désert tu veux dire qu'on
faire des kilomètres pour voir un visage
avec ce mur qui entoure la propriété sur
le téléphone et la voiture que serions
nous des chartreux enfin elle plaît à
ton père ainsi mais il oublie qu'il est
parti à l usine toute la journée tandis
que nous nous sommes ici à nous ennuyer
enfin c'est comme ça il se débarasse
mêmes intérêts quand je vois je veillais
monsieur dans quelques minutes
aussi chez les moins de 6 ans quand ma
chère et il a demandé qu'on le dérange
pas là
merci louise merci elle est bien cette
film est très bien la fin j'en suis très
contente oui
viens et accepter de s'en faire mais ici
à je crois que c'est une chance pour
nous non une chance oui tu sur un site
ne fait pas de la gymnastique dessus
concasseur 10 avec catherine est devenu
turbulent alors cette son logement
voyons catherine lève toi aux sétois
parce que catherine salève mais ce que
je sais bush attaques estime thomas faty
toujours pareil comme je peux meyrin mon
coeur la neige réveil mes rhumatismes
enfin alors déjà de retour pourquoi
éviter des gens on t'a rendu du collage
non au contraire j'ai de très bonne
heure je sais je sais que ta mère nous a
montré ton car les scolaires seulement
un carnet ça se maquille on dit tout ça
ce n'est pas gentil
ma nièce arrive du collège peut pas lui
demander si c'est bien conduite non
c'est pour ça que je te dis tout va bien
voilà hulot - qui est contente de son
sort c'est pour moi que tu dises a dit
ma fille est heureuse voilà tout c'est
l'essentiel non alors puisque c'est
l'essentiel
tu as des ennuis tout de lui sinon elle
centrée quoi je manquerais quoi je
manquerais ok je vous en prie nôtre
commence c'est pas suis heureuse mois
voilà du nouveau et augustine soit calme
j'aime pas à plaindre bien mais nous
avons que gay gentiment grâce à el
maghra sahel grâce à ton père suis on
qui nous estime à notre juste valeur
c'est respecter une dame âgée est
infirme comme ta grand mère femme
vertueuse et droite comme moi grâce à
marcel oui quand même de bien sûr
détente augustine ne sois pas triste
nous t'aimons tout ici sans exception ne
nous fait pas de seins nus pas dormi de
la nuit
pardon gaby ma chérie grâce à toi je
suis heureuse et je mange à ma faim la
savate et qu'on tente le petit déjeuner
le café channels et 180 mo ou des
brioches tout sauf une droit qu'à du
pain grillé moi comme tout le monde
mademoiselle augustine mais ces brioches
sont mon cadeau personnel à massu sont
retrouvés à
dia nancy ça fait plaisir
oh oui merci jamais brioche où j'ai dû
chocolat dans ma chambre j'ai cherché
les brioches
c'est toujours mes gars avec du chocolat
il faut être indulgent tu es une vraie
gamine la mairie très gentil de tolérer
ses petites manies sens passé comme ça
des manies validant sont presque des
insolences à ne pas prendre à tout
moment enfin puisque ton père la
tolèrent comme paris hilton 29 avril
toujours des toujours de bonne humeur
et pourtant ces affaires ne vont pas
comme il voudrait alors là tu es mieux
renseigné que moi maman sur les soucis
de marcel qui ignorent même si dans
l'avenir par hasard et c'est très bien
comme ça tu penses j'ai mes problèmes
ils allaient science on parle jamais
tout est pour le mieux je les consulte
et récemment pour la vente de mes titres
et incidemment il m'a dit qu'à un mot tu
les as vendu des titres non marseille
m'a conseillé d'attendre à bata raison
garder on sait jamais
catherine catherine la citoyen casseurs
est arrivé à l'esat catherine dutreix
elle travaille bien avec là haut ça peut
aller quoi elle a beaucoup grandi tu
sais enfin elle va bien cette principale
rays exubérante comme génération et
alors cela voudrait une heure asthénique
comme augusti à la saison
[Musique]
on attend ça s'est tranquillement dans
20 du matin dans la nuit le ce qu'aulas
m'a dit non tu n'es pas content et
d'internet
je croyais qu'à 15 ans on aimait les
chocolats 15 ans il pousse j'en aurai ce
texte en février
tu m'as l'air en pleine forme saga ça
carbure ça fonctionne en un mot ça boume
mahdi dont l'angleterre pas trop
demander ça mais tu devrais aller
frapper à la porte de papa il n'est pas
encore réveillé non quelle flamme à
robin le mien dans cette maison le
respect n'est toute personne non mais je
respecte mon père à ma manière voilà
tout et surtout je la mire il égaye
s'habille comme à londres il conduit
comme un champion il brasse des fortunes
comme un chercheur d'or
nous avons la chance qu'ils ont notre
père est un véritable héros de romans
dit ce qu'il m'a permis d'apprendre à
conduire
on s'entend bien tous les deux on est
comme deux complices et puis c'est le
seul homme de la maison tient là la plus
belle
maintenant podium
pas mécontent à quel sujet madame la
duchesse tu as laissé ta lumière à
l'humus kg née keller travers la porte
vitrée et m'empêchait de dormir tu
lisais encore sans doute des livres
abominable quel livre abominable temps
augustine apple livre abominable des
romans policiers d'aventuré d'espionnage
garde ton argent mon âge
lire le facteur à personne mais a laissé
un froid dans la salle de bain la nuit
ça réveille les voisins c'est moi qui
suis allé parfaitement en tête est
malade je ne pouvais pas dormir je suis
allé boire
excuse moi monsieur oui je vous en prie
c'est un aveu ne faut pas l'homme
catherine comme ça je pourrais peut-être
dormir merci tu me choisira le petit
chaperon rouge la belle au bois dormant
tu me donneras l'argent j'irai acheter
moins de la banque du beurre barrot
tricks gaga sort de pouvoir dormir avec
tout bruit que nous faisons moi quand
une pendule sonne à l'autre bout de la
maison ce sursaut les hommes sont
d'autres nerfs nous
voilà à peine maladroite à bonne idée
que vous avez d'engager cette fille on
se demande où elle a créé son métier
celle là sylvia louise c'est affreux ça
fait beaucoup d'ennemis
commentant n'entre pas dans la chambre
merci à nous d'attaquer dans la chambre
parce que vous dites
ils se disent que tout le monde ici
oubliez de dire personne ne veut toucher
à quoi que ce soit avant l'arrivée de la
police n'a pas ma petite fille maman
c'est trop grave n'entre pas dans la
chambre et vous ne voulez tout de même
pas dire que je ne veux pas entrer par
marcel mais enfin dit quelque chose et
revit je ne fais pas catherine a
peut-être en raison les urnes autistes
ou doosan ne toucher à rien pour les
empreintes
mais non voyons je dois rentrer
mais la porte est fermée
catherine que tu fais tu as fait
remédier a pris la clef je la donnerai
aux commissaires aux comptes
cette chance voilà catherine catherine
catherine a tué quelque chose que
quelqu'un pour faire disparaître les
catherine deux mallettes rien moi te
trouves pas possible a eu le courage
suzan oui maman deuil oui mais bon soir
salle peut-être encore dans la chambre
la région firme nous faire mon film avec
moi on s'est dit c'est bien mais tu es
bien qu'annoncée gentiane sa dépouille à
y penser mais non pas tant que ça sur
les temps
ces affaires avaient trop mal il s'est
suicidé pas suicidé j'ai bien vu le
couteau est enfoncée dans son homme au
couteau mais à couteaux commandes au
genre de poignard feignait rappelez moi
j'ai encore mes personnages
monsieur me l'avait demandé pour
découper du carton cartons-caisses
cuzals qui cartonne faut téléphoner à la
police nous a manqué trop tard c
y'a pas de tonalité
ça ne répond pas
on a coupé le fil du téléphone qui
quelqu'un
vous croyez que quelqu'un est encore
dans la maison
j'entends du bruit par là
monsieur la girouette votre imagination
mais qu'est ce qu'on va devenir c'est
toby ça ne vient pas il viendra jamais
je vais chercher en voiture 8 momenta
oui tout de suite à quoi les chiottes
puncheur qui n'ont pas envoyé de la nuit
il est alors pas méchant commission il y
aura payé si c'est quoi vous voulez dire
si un étranger était entré dans la
propriété
oui c'est ça mais là si personne n'est
venu de l'extérieur ça veut dire quoi
et c'est moi maintenant
mais le jeu n'est plus tenable
il faut vous allez devoir oui il faut
que madame à y voir
ah oui oui oui ça il faut que quelqu'un
prenne cette responsabilité oui il le
faut je suis cardiaque
mais bon
[Musique]
ouais alors si je comprends bien
personne n'ose bouger
[Musique]
que s'est-il passé hier soir un rien de
spécial entrée vers les huit heures nous
avons dîné et puis il est remonté dans
sa chambre pour travailler il n'a par
cette visite non on va tous et avec le
temps qu'il fait ferait du courage pour
gravir la colline pas de coups de
téléphone aux non pas que je sache on
aurait entendu la sonnerie dans le
vagabond un voleur qui étaient
introduits et coutumes on dit maman
louis d'or au dessus du garage dans ce
cas-là entendu les chiens ils n'ont pas
oublié de lui je suis sûr
alors je serai quelqu'un de la maison un
familier de la maison
qui a téléphoné la dernière qui a
téléphoné la dernière moi et m'a dit le
jour dit ce matin vers les huit heures
et demie j'ai téléphoné au boucher pour
en voir de l'avion le gigot la banque ce
matin à 7h30 l'assassin est encore ici
il a coupé les fils du téléphone après
or il faut se rendre à l'évidence
à
les affaires de papa marché talent oui
c'est comment il et on perd à brasseurs
d'argent un homme d'action très
intelligent il avait mille et un tours
dans son sac pour réussir
on va personnellement il m'a jamais dit
que ça n'allait pas bien et puis il est
admirablement second départ monsieur
farnoux messieurs par nous oui son
nouvel associé à l'usiné oui
ce monsieur est il déjà venu ici non si
enfin une fois ou deux peut-être nous le
fringant dans absolument pas enfin très
peu je me souviens que le jour où ils
venus chercher monsieur les chiens ou à
moitié renversé parce que monsieur
pharma a chez lui un chien et que les
nôtres l'avait senti donc il faut
abandonner l'idée que ce monsieur bien
sûr voyons c'est invraisemblable à la
4e' la connaissez vous quelqu'un qui
aurait pu vouloir du mal à pas par pur
sang nous éviter quand il a paris on
sait pas au juste qui fréquentaient
qu'est ce que tu vas imaginer un
étranger dans notre salon et 8h coupant
les fils du téléphone et personne ne le
voit que rends tu compte tenu de ce que
ça représente pour nous tout ici qui est
restée bien ne pas pas moi je
je veux dire nous plaît dans ce cas je
crois qu'on vend l'usiné on partage
entre la la famille et les enfants
là il est l'auteur ça tout ça bien sûr
la femme à la moitié quand vous donne à
chacun de l'argent utilisé
tu comprends rien catherine chercher un
mouchoir
il faudra prévenir la soeur de papa la
soeur de ton père ben en voilà une idée
par exemple une femme pareille oui tu
m'a écrit dernièrement que l'été venu
s'installer dans la maison près du
village
pourquoi dans l'espoir sans doute de
renouer avec ton père après la vie de
débauche qu'elle a menée à paris elle a
essayé de renouer avec son frère
enfin j'ai pas voulu influencer tempère
le laissant libre de recevoir cette +7
pierrette et après tout et sa soeur mais
a très bien compris que ce ne serait pas
convenable et il ne nous l'a jamais
présenté cette fille dieu merci n'a
jamais mis les pieds dans cette maison
en quoi papa at il revu ça sert en ville
sûrement pas comment est-elle parce que
je sais du jamais vu - on l'a montré de
loin
c'est une belle femme assez étrange de
quoi dit elle alors ça mystère
j'aimerais lui parler il le perdra où tu
voudras mais pas dans cette maison que
la france laisse faire la police c'est
son rôle de poser des questions pas le
tien louise mon manteau je suis absente
depuis plus d'un an et je vois tout avec
des yeux neufs
c'est fou comme un âne or les visages
changent
tu trouves que j'ai veillé de cette
catastrophe va bien se charger de me
donner mon âge marcel aux parcelles nous
comprenions nous étions tendrement unis
au point de faire chambre à part
martial rentrée talent parfois il
travailla souvent la nuit
il m'avait demandé quand est très
provisoirement la chambre bus dont tu as
quelque chose à ajouter pour l'instant
petit calmez vous il ne faut pas rester
sans aide par avec la voiture gaby
dépêche toi je vais tout de suite et
nous ne pouvons pas laisser ce pauvre
monsieur tout seul si madame le permet
je vais monter mais la sacem et être
encore là mais n'ont fait pas de
rembrandt ma petite fille nous a pas
attendu il s'est sauvé on a fait
connaissance on veut sauter sur le toit
du garage mais non il a dû partir par la
porte comme il est venu
ça ça est beaucoup plus fort qu'on ne
croit le proche plus que voulez vous
dire je me comprends
la clé n'est pas dans la serrure quoi
qui a pris la clef c'est vous madame
monsieur bonsoir moi ce qui est la clé
c'est augustine tu à la clé la clé c'est
usant mais non ça tue alors oui oui
c'est invraisemblable qui a pu la
prendre mais si fort madame je me suis
évanoui à jeter mégabits
moi aussi d'ailleurs nous sommes tous
montés nous il est allé chercher des
sols catherine un mouchoir madame
tshamala koussa et mme ami à moi j'ai
pas bougé on l'a mise dans mon tricot et
bane approfondissons pas madame chanel
j'ai eu une parfaite confiance en vous
vous êtes peut-être la seule dans cette
maison à qui je vais donner la clé sans
arrière pensée que c'est agréable pour
les autres si vous êtes la plus
courageuse madame charnelle tenez prenez
la clé merci mais n'ont pas pu nous
consulter nos fais ce que je crois être
mon devoir revoir madame charlène
laisser entrer personne non alors si
madame chan alors que nous devons tout
en tant qu'invité aux personnes aux 12
coups dans le dos j'ai rien contre
et vous assis nu et que j'ai demandé la
clé dans ce but on veut très bien dans
ce cas quand madame fans elle ne soyez
pas susceptible sésame il était
susceptible c'est pour ça que je sers
depuis 15 ans dans cette maison on peut
bien me dire tout ce qu'on veut ça m'est
égal je suis là pour gagner ment pas
c'est tout d'ailleurs je peux bien vous
le dire j'avais peur autant que vous
alors cette clé qui la veut qu'il
accorde
terrain bon je la pose là
c'est noël cet homme qui rôdent peut
être autour de nous alors pourquoi non
qu'est ce que ça peut être d'autre mais
une femme sur auto vous avez l'art de
nous accuser la conscience tranquille
l'un des tests n'est ce pas moi corps te
mets à différents vu un tandem musulmane
ou tais toi
gaby excuse bien évidemment tap to shoot
attaque ou si sa maman donne raison à
gavi elle est riche à présent très riche
et il va nous mettre dehors alors faites
à courre maman son ton beefsteak
vous ne dis rien lui dire parce que vous
êtes tout hélas mais moi je dis
l'addition à la police des choses que je
sais quel show c'est mon affaire
la même attaque de fois tu préfères toi
attaqué tôt
[Rires]
je suis malgré tout le monde dit que je
suis une idiote mais c'est pourquoi
fruit sec gov
mais quelques jours - comme consolation
dites moi pas de moi ni la ville
physique pour faire la pub hossa ni la
mentalité va pleurer savez la poésie
cuisine
la fête de ma chambre je vois la
demi-heure portait une parka récitant
des vers paroles qu'on n'est pas des
moindres le garde oui c'est important de
distraction dans ce coin perdu la
demoiselle augustine le soir en train de
déclamer sma télévision moellons
calme-toi vêtu boire quelque chose pour
te dit anti hollande - quoique ce soit
que tu peux la table tiens je croyais
que tu étais allé sa foi dans la salle
de bain cette nuit pour voir au lit
c'est différent je suis une grande
malade moi je suis gardien va prendre
des cachets pour te caldégas ccsa des
casseurs mêlés prendre le méca se tient
toute la boîte comme ça vous souhaitez
passer deux mois
ce moment non maman voyons des jambes ça
va
bah ça alors elle marche dont faut
croire que c'était bien la peine de nous
faire acheter cette chaise roulante
tout est organisé entre elle et son
auguste il n'en suis qu'à rémois mais
que fait madame et mais je pars lui
demande en temps ça fait parfois je vous
le demande la omar 5 mars elle s'était
bouvard table fait froid je vais mettre
une bûche maman parle-moi de papa parce
qu'il a fait depuis mon départ
depuis vous avez recueilli mami est
tantôt christine pour père seif c'était
la bonté me tue le connaissez aussi bien
que moi et mieux sans doute car tu lui
rapporter tout avant que je le sache
mamie est tantôt christine s'entendait
bien avec lui je l'espère avec ce
qu'elle mange qu'elle faisait au moins
la reconnaissance du ventre sont parfois
disputé avec lui mais en face c'était
pas gras disputés à propos de quoi des
bêtises et augustine fait un drame de
rien et mamie d'or avec des titres sous
son oreiller mamie à des titres caché
sous son oreiller
as tu parles qu'elle garde comme un
chien sont en hausse j'ai dix mille
francs qui a donné à marseille pour les
mettre dans ces affaires c'est bien
normal non penses-tu les couve ses
titres auraient été utiles à papa ah oui
oui indispensable à quinze jours tient
pour une échéance à laquelle il devait
faire face ces affaires allaient mal à
ma chérie une échéance et d'une échéance
mais ça n'aurait rien fait que mamie
dispose de cet argent car tu as ta par
dessus
justement j'ai donné ma part à marcel
après avoir littéralement arraché les
mâles grand mère augustine sans les
mails et naturellement la bataille a
repris et pour cause c'est un détail
c'est grave un nom c'est fait enfin tu
sais qu'elles sont fâchés je ne sais pas
tu viens de me le dire en face rien du
tout pas mamie et augustine sont
écartelés entre la reconnaissance
qu'elle nous doit et leur avarice voilà
enfin que veux tu elles n'ont pas
rencontré un mari riche elle laisse ma
faute
quand je pense à tout ce que j'ai fait
pour que marcel les accepte ici
en vérité ton père ne pouvait pas les
voir
mon père a toujours aimé la jeunesse a
enfin mon manteau eux
merci louise depuis combien de temps
avez vous à la maison exactement
pourquoi vous me demandez saint louis
est là depuis deux mois
j'aime penser artifical tu travaillé
deux ans dans la terre qui s'est retirée
ou peut vérifier n'est pas mon rôle
louise vous êtes bien certaines du
silence des chiens certaine j'ai mal
dormi cette nuit je fais un
pressentiment hier monsieur avait
mauvaise mine quand j'ai monté sa tisane
vous et vous a demandé une tisane mais
termine lui à 15 heures minuit c'était
son habitude pas du tout non pourquoi de
la tisane j'ai travaillé il a dû avoir
soif mal à l'estomac
il avait la lumière encore lu mais dans
la cuisine massot mais je suis monté ma
demande et eagle sur descendu lui ferait
je mentais vous êtes resté longtemps
dans la chambre de mon père non je suis
reparti aussitôt éteint comment se
fait-il que je n'ai pas fait le plateau
dans la chambre tout à l'heure parce que
j'ai remporté hier soir pourquoi voulez
vous dire que vous étiez remonter
aussitôt parce que c est un but à paris
ajoute toute la boîte un ce serait trop
beau
je peux disposer montant des quand vous
avez fait le tilleul madame chanel était
encore dans la maison
non elle venait de partir elle a vite le
pavillon de chasse a fondu par pour sa
liberté dit-elle oui je sais c'est une
bonne nounou plein de vieilles habitudes
de pensée sans droit après le travail on
est libre de faire ce qu'on veut depuis
ça n'a jamais fait de mal à personne de
jouer aux cartes au madame chanel je
m'écarte maintenant aux madmoizelles ne
savais pas ensuite j'ai fait une gaffe
ou non a dit tout non je sais que madame
chan elle aime jouer aux cartes mais
avec qui joue tel avec quelqu'un de la
maison c'est pas mon genre de mouches
harper dit non avec qui elle joue et
nous le dirons à personne elle joua au
puisque tu m'en fiche elle joue avec
mademoiselle le pire est la soeur de mon
père ça non comme on avait poussé mamie
les a vus et elle me l'a dit un jour de
confidences sur les 20 petits verres
dans le nez après il ya toujours une
bonne petite bouteille dans la forme de
ma vie et comment est elle met un petit
air est à saché pas l a jamais mis les
pieds ici
ancienne danseuse nue dit ces dames
artistes de talent et pur comme alice du
vrm chanel moi je veux bien
elle profite de sa jeunesse pour faire
marcher quelques-uns la patte après tout
comment pierrette avec talent jusqu'au
pavillon de chasse de madame chanel elle
fait du stop jusqu'au carrefour de la
route nation mais d'haruna ici il ya
encore deux kilomètres
l'effet pied le bitume art on these sans
rayons non le mal rasé l'auguste in la
porte et lui ça
quelle comédienne d'attention justin on
l'entend durée de la cuisine enfin je
suis quand même fait sentir
pourquoi dis-tu comedian voilà jamais
été malade tu t'en numéro mamie et
intestines que tu connaissais peu que
penses tu des gentils mais un peu
encombrant ta pauvre mère n'est plus
chez elle elle n'arrête pas de lui faire
des réflexions de la morale à ya quelque
chose sur laquelle elles ont raison
c'est l'éducation de catherine être
calme en éducation tu parles mal tu
marches du chewing-gum à table tu fumes
tout le temps et il y dix romans
abominable avec des couvertures macao de
couverture makobola là tu souhaitais pas
dans le coup à toi ma prison tu étais
plus à la maison de caractère différent
voilà tout chanel à quelle heure et tu
sorti hier soir vers minuit les allées
de promener vois tu tu manques par un
temps pareil tu as reçu des visites les
visites
voilà dix ans que je n'ai pas reçues
catherine je tire pas si un pantalon de
la lingerie va s'habiller correctement
et plus vite que ça
au mas du channel est ce que louise
travaille bien à sur ce chapitre là je
peux te dire ce que je pense
oui c'est une coquine qui va de
placement en place dans l'espoir de
coucher avec le patron quant aux aux uns
et aux autres je m'en charge
il faut absolument que je fasse une
confidence n'y a que toi en qui j'ai
confiance
voilà ton père n'avait plus d'argent
personne ne le sait que moi mais c'est
très important explique toi j'ai voulu
donner à marcel en reconnaissance pour
notre hébergement des titres que je
tiens de ton grand père le colonel il
les a refusées et il m'a dit 40 et votre
argent
il serait impuissant avait sauvé de la
faillite alors pour ne pas le trahir
j'ai joué pour la famille celle qui
refuse de donner ses titres ensuite que
tu fais rien j'ai gardé mes filtres pas
pour longtemps
parce que parce que parce qu'on les a
poli qu'il ya deux jours venez on a
drogué mon porto oui un petit verre de
porto après le repas fait du bien mais
douleur on m'a drogués on est inquiet
dans la chambre et on m'a volé chez
quelqu'un qui savait la cachette sous
son oreille et seront là comment sais tu
tout le monde semble savoir monde bande
de voleurs voilà voilà
c'est maman qui a perdu la tête n'ont
pas la tête non
grevé revient pas non c'est qu'on lui a
volé ses petites rivières sur l'éthique
mort 2 tu les as vendu en cachette et tu
veux me donner là pas mal s'affolait
voyons quitte les aurait pris je ne sors
jamais de match en tentant bouger toutes
les nuits j'entends craque et on part
ken norton jeannette jamais j'écoute
spatiale mais écoutez si tu es petit tu
n'étais pas là dire eh bien tout ce qui
m'est arrivé d'entendre ma pauvre
augustine note ici mais c'est toi qui a
pris les types de mort
quoi
que personne ne bronche pour la voiture
[Musique]
les natures qu'elles ont gt3 malheureuse
avec maman venue ici trop pauvre pauvre
quand je me suis retrouvée seule à la
mort de ton père le colonel spectateurs
et toi elysées catherine pense pas mon
truc qu il a bien fallu que je travaille
qu'une femme seule qui est affreux dhabi
va connaître ça maintenant
l'aviron commence toujours elle lave on
te regarde j'espère que gaby elle ne
fera pas de différence entre ses deux
filles en temps celle qui est déjà une
dame est et l'autre la passe pour
l'abonné rien n'inquiète pas pour moi
les complexes et pas maureilhan ça
viendra moi ça commençait ovale
moi j'ai horreur du bal moi aussi mais
j'y allais quand même pour faire comme
les autres pour me faire des relations à
moi je m'en suis jamais fait
alors un jour j'ai décidé depuis y aller
c'était fini je suis resté avec maman on
a dit le patron se disputer au du style
je t'aime bien moment quoi que tu en
penses
j'aime bien tout le monde personne
comprend ma façon d'aimer on croit que
c'est de la m
c'est comme la bondrée conway pas ça
fait divines et l'attrait d'un doigt
nous avons toutes nos pas et nos excuses
à présent il faut oublier les petites
choses et faire face aux grandes et les
grandes jour de ton arrivée assassiné un
couteau dans l'automobile et sur cette
question tu as dit vrai l'assassin est
dans la maison
vous voilà c'est une des taquets
c'est la faute de ta mère elle lui
laisse lire n'importe quel livre du
calot avec un lumière qui n'ont pas de
dormir
enfin je ne veux pas accabler à présent
ma pauvre soeur parce que parce que
parce que ça ne me regarde pas et que je
ne le dirais
non non non non ça ne me regarde pas je
mets qui l'a pas
dirais pas que diaby réclamé à cor et à
cri et surtout à cri de l'argent à
marseille c'est le dépenser à tort et à
travers dieu sait avec qui ça ne me
regarde pas je ne le dirai pas non plus
ton père un homme si bon utiliser une
rumeur qu'elle la mouche est un homme
pareil tout ce qu'il a fait pour moi
justin louis pour nous aussi ne manquez
pas il manquait jamais acheté des
bonbons du chocolat c'est vrai nous
avoir hébergé ici malgré mes résultats
mais ça soit bien le moment venu et ça
c'est tout le monde avant alors qu'ils
passent ils se pensent que la voiture ne
part pas on n'achète tous les fils du
moteur ont arraché il ya ma garde a pas
un seul envoi les insolents sur les
constatations au premier interrogatoire
de la police
je serai obligé de dire que vous sortez
très souvent le soir ma fille et que
tout le monde le sait premier
interrogatoire de la police sera obligé
de dire que vous sortez très souvent le
soir madame et que tout le monde ignore
il ya des lois contre les faux
témoignage mais aussi des lois pour
mériter ça signifie il faut prévenir le
notaire le notaire pourquoi pour
l'héritage vous savez bien à qui profite
le crime
j'avoue je ne comprends pas bah oui la
personne qui rit de l'assassiner
forcément là ça sonne tous les bouquins
policiers nice du 1er d'apprendre la
géographie et toi tu tiens c'est bien la
première fois que tu occupes cette étude
doit annoncer
peterson sollicitons partir à pied j
veux jouer avec toi annoncé courir
jusqu'au bord de la route mon malheur
dépêche toi ma petite fille cet
isolement est intolérable
regardez regardez qu'un marche dans le
jardin
c'est la saq et on vient les écoutes je
me sens mal je leur donne
regardez
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi mesdames ne serait jamais
permis de venir ici sans être invité
mais les circonstances ont brouillé offs
et bien que c'est ridicule mais j'ai
reçu il ya une heure un coup de
téléphone neuf russes plaisanterie sans
doute on a dit venez vite votre frère a
été assassiné et puis on a raccroché
alors j'ai appelé ici mais votre
téléphone doit être en dérangement
puis tout à coup vêtements j'ai eu peur
le boulanger m'a déposé en bas là sur la
route
pourquoi me regarde et vous tout comme
ça c'était une plaisanterie lesparre
répondait pour des dons pourquoi la
chambre de mon frère était elle fermée
comment savez vous que c'est sa chambre
bout qui n'est jamais venu ici c'est que
c'est toute cette porte et ne criait non
pas comme ça marcel est mort non un
couteau dans le dos
je crois -
vous admettrez que devant votre éruption
je me trouve obligée de vous poser
quelques questions au laissez moi je
vous en prie vous reconnu la voix qui
vous téléphonez me par les noms de
femmes
oui quand je ne crois guère avec tout
téléphone et dans quel but
moi j'ai inventé tout ça on pourra avoir
un prétexte pour venir ici que dis-je
pour y revenir car vous êtes déjà venu
n'est ce pas jamais pourquoi les chiens
n'ont ils pas envoyer les semble bien
l'habitude est à vous c'est pourquoi la
porte et elles fermées pour empêcher
quiconque de toucher quoi que ce soit et
qui a la clé où tout
moi je veux voir marseille donnez moi
c'est lui je veux entrer pour faire
disparaître quelque chose que vous
auriez laissez derrière vous sans doute
donner moins c'est plus que j'enfonce la
porte
prenez-la vous met à gueuler sur cette
table
[Musique]
enfin cette les n'ouvre pas comment
regardez vous même c'est plus la clé on
l'a changé
pas de téléphone pas de voiture et plus
de clés unis ci travaille contre nous
tout n'est plus passif un prix qu'ils
voudraient saisir à ce que vous dites
c'est très gras moderne vous pas résisté
meetic a des grands mères moi aussi je
suppose le pire
nous avons tourné autour de cette clé y
compris quand pierrette qui en montant
de doha pour faire la substitution mois
gardée prisonnière non appelez ça comme
vous voulez parfait
et d'abord que je suis votre nièce suzon
mois catherine moi je suis mamie et oui
bon hein
quand avez vous vu mon mari pour la
dernière fois
nous sommes fâchés vous le savez bien ne
me dites pas que vous le rencontriez
jamais je ne vous croirez pas oui j'ai
rencontré mon frère pour deux par hasard
ils m'aimaient beaucoup et souffrait qui
ont interdit l'accès de cette maison
c'est un an nous en tout cas passer d'un
policier est dans la maison mais ce coup
de téléphone semble avoir voulu me
joindre à vous c'est clair pourquoi la
ccin vous aurez t-il averti bien sûr oui
c'est invraisemblable dans mon frère est
mort alors je suis décidé à vous
soupçonner tout d'avancé par principe
comment vous êtes beaucoup plus
soupçonnable que nous avons trouvé vous
le fait que vous ayez voulu fuir trouve
que vous êtes coupable
vous allez prévenir la police un mort de
mon frère me prive de tout ce qui me
restait au monde
en perdant je suis plus seul que jamais
tandis que vous c'est la liberté la
richesse l'accusé mois deux semaines et
pourquoi pas perdre la tête
je suis la belle mère de marcel et voici
mon autre fille augustine nous étions
hébergés par mon gendre transfert en
moselle j'avais de l'argent figurez-vous
il ya deux jours on me l'a volé mamans
et aux bons mètres mais de mesurer au
courant tout de suite alors c'est vous
augustine mais j'étais curieuse de vous
connaître et pour quelle raison s'il
vous plaît parce que nous sommes abonnés
au même club de lecture tu es japonais
un club de lecture tu me l'avais jamais
qui excusez moi j'ai gaffé an plus tôt
je suis inscrite 10 points jamais rien
ma fille il n'aime pas lui il y aura
vraiment je suis abonnée moi aussi et la
secrétaire qui est bavarde m'a dit que
vos poignets au moins cinq romans par
semaine tous des romans d'amour
vous vous trompez possible en tout cas
vous avez lu il ya huit jours
la gondole des amants nom qu'on doive de
demain c'est plus beau et plus sûrement
jusqu'à prévu pour le hasard ou presque
à bages a été comblée entre les pages du
livre j'ai trouvé quelque chose vous
appartenant c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé
intéressé avoue qu avez-vous trouvé dans
ce lycée ma fille a laissé quelque chose
rendu là lui et j'ai tout avait oublié
le brouillon d'une lettre vous avez
adressé à mon frère marcel comment tu
écrivais à marcel que tu voyais tous les
jours tu n'as gossio de cette noble
intention n'est pas de chance je
conserve tout oui c'est une très très
vieille habitude voilà cher marcel il ne
faut pas m'en vouloir d'avoir c'est une
scène à maman devant toi à propos des
titres j'étais obligé de réclamer ma
part pour ne pas qu'elle soupçonne le
trop grand intérêt que je te parle
s'il avait tenu qu'à moi je te les
aurait donnés c'était etc
sache que je suis capable de tout pour
s'éviter des ennuis mais cesse de mardi
avec camille qui habite je glisse ce mot
sutapa et embrasse affectueusement signé
si jamais mais marcel au contraire je
détestais c'était connaisseurs il avait
dès qu'ils ont un peu partout et je
retenais mes titres pour qui les porte à
ses maîtresses garder sa soeur avec son
sourire
il faut faire une famille ma fille ne
sait plus quel double paire et des
menaces mais c'est pas vrai j'ai pas tué
je n'ai pas bougé la somme de la nuit
pardon dessin fois dans la salle de bain
cette semaine dans les salles de bains
guys and brave homme ivre est pour cette
diversion sur augustine
vous êtes très sortent seulement nous
avons quelques questions à vous poser
vous écoute
êtes vous déjà venu ici là mais vous
mentent et nous en avons la preuve
merci chanel je dis rien dit pierrette
qu'est ce que ça signifie
oui ils se connaissent se rencontrent je
le sais elle adore tout de jouer aux
cartes ou vous rencontrez vous chez moi
le soir en ville c'est notre droit non
quitterait faut pas que chanel fait 9 km
dans la nuit pour faire une partie de
cartes oui vous mentez encore je faisais
demandé tout à l'heure si vous étiez
déjà venu ici au vous êtes tourné vers
shannon donc vous veniez ici et chanel
le savez mieux elle vous accompagner et
les chiens sont habitués à vous répond t
au
autant dire pire est je la recevrai dans
mon pavillon où souvent il passait la
nuit et wall et du pavillon à la maison
la distance n'a pas dû être longue à
franchir je suis venu ici un jour voir
mon frère
j'avais quelque chose d'important à lui
dire c'était si important
madame shannon ne pouvait pas faire les
commissions écouter et ses constants
sont graves
quand la police arrive rend si elle
arrive lui car personne ne semble décidé
à aller la chercher elle prendra
beaucoup moins d'eau quand nous pour
découvrir toutes les vérités qui se
cache dans cette maison thor fait un
effort pour parler elle venait sans
doute lui demander de l'argent
j'ai jamais demandé de l'argent à marcel
mais vous en a donné lui même n'est ce
pas parfaitement c'est inconcevable
inventé toi papa et elie vous n'avez pas
la question
cette fille soutirent de l'argent mon
mari je ne pourrai rien dire mais cet
argent a été témoin de ma partenaire
emma rose et le droit maintenant il est
tout à fait moi l'amour de l'argent vous
étouffe sa chère ville sont attendus le
samedi
cet avis alors inspecteur vous êtes en
quête s'avance
écoutez il s'agit de savoir ce que tout
nous avons fait exactement cette nuit si
moment où étais-tu way dans ma chambre
quelle question tu t'es levé n'en
compterait personne non personne
si si si je j'ai cru entendre clac et le
volet de la porte de catherine je
pensais qu'elle était malade je suis
monté mais c'était rien alors je suis
remonté dans ma chambre qui n'a
rencontré personne dans couloir
si non je plus tu fus catherine qui est
élevé oui pour elle aussi coin roma du
matin je n'ai vu personne
tu n'as rien entendu oh tu sais j'étais
plongé dans mon bouquin policiers j'ai
pas fait attention aussi un moment tu
augustine m'a demandé d'éteindre tu lui
a répondu ah oui ah ouais ingremeau des
pestes tu as fait ça je voulais pas dire
mais tant pis pour toi voilà au moment
où je me suis recouché j'ai entendu un
drôle de bruit
j'ai regardé chez auguste par le trou de
la serrure et je les fuis devant sa
glace avec dans les mains quelque chose
qui brillait sur le moment je n'ai pas
réagi
après ça j'en suis sûr c'était un
couteau elle aiguisait tête veulent tout
et la turquie tourner la tête et tu les
plus - la gondole d amour puisque je
tenais et de mon pain et blanc en nacre
que le nettoyeur à 3 heures du matin
yab vendeur pour les paye
tantôt distille nous croyons qui nous a
bien dit n'est ce pas que tu veux faire
les cinq fois dans la salle de bain
ouais tu as rencontré quelqu'un personne
as tu entendu des pas de porte claque
mais j'ai pas fait attention pardon tu
pouvais pas dormir
quelqu'un qui peut pas dormir et nerveux
le moindre bruit fait sursauter
tu nous as dit avoir entendu mamie
slovènie cet examen alors mamie tu t'es
levé non merci je suis levé vers une
cellule picot dans mon lit très tard et
j'ai soudain penser que l'ain l'aisne
qui me restait était dans le salon c'est
chez lui la chercher pour pouvoir
travailler de bonne heure dans mon lit
as-tu croiser quelqu'un à la lumière de
brûler chez catherine et j'ai augustine
il n'a semblé entendre des éclats de
voix dans les chambres de marcel mais je
n'ai pas distingue des piqûres liège 12
points capté fait penser que c'était toi
tu entendu crier j'ai pensé que c'était
même mais je te remercie dis donc ça
fait toujours plaisir prendre à dire par
sa mère que l'on vit avec son mari à
couteaux tirés
oh oui avez vous quelque chose à dire
ceux ses éclats quoi venant de la
chambre de mon père non quand j'ai monté
son tir là monsieur il était seul vous
n'avez rencontré personne
si la demoiselle augustine pour ça y est
ça recommence
tiens mais tu viens de nous dire quand
augustine d'avoir rencontré personne on
mais j'avais oublié
j'étais allé boire et encore elle a
passé sa nuit à voir ou à peine croisé
matin exactement vers la pendule ancien
la pendue anciens mais 80 augustine si
ma mémoire est bonne
la pendule ancien n'est pas entre ta
chambre la salle de bains rap sa dette
au moment où je suis allé dire à
catherine d'éteindre leurs eaux des deux
côtés de la chambre de marcel 1
qu'est ce qui s'est passé tu l'auras si
tu ne faisais pas chambre à part se
faire juger passé en france est affreux
non c'est pour cette raison ma belle je
n'en ai jamais à quelle heure même
chalet du parti je n'ai pas regardé
madame c'était aux environs de minuit
était avant ou après le tilleul vers ce
moment là j'ai entendu monsieur
commandés et je suis parti un peu après
oui combien de temps après cinq minutes
au plus que ça dans ce camp louise
occupe ma cuisine gens ni pour un bon
moment à remettre de l'ordre
surtout qu'elle a tenu à le faire
elle-même ce tir
louise pourquoi avez vous tenu à le
faire vous même c'est tilleuls monsieur
me l'avait commandé à moi c'était normal
et vous vouliez l'alimenter vous même
pourquoi dites-vous savannah est
longtemps j'ai vu clair dans votre jeu
et ma fille comme madame voudra je
préfère est accusé de viscom 9 ha bon
eh bien il me reste plus qu'à vous
demandez où vous étiez ou pire est où
étiez vous y asseoir
je suis allé faire une visite
personnelle qui ne regarde que moi qui
n'a rien à voir avec une bouleverse donc
vous l'avez pas vu mon mari hier soir
c'est certes un certain alors jusqu'à
preuve du contraire
la dernière personne à avoir vu marcel
vivant c'est c'est vous louise grog on
peut m'accuser morte ça sans aucun doute
pourquoi j'aime pas les ennuis je vais
tout dire sous l'excusé nous incline est
il le fruit je m'y attendais voilà quand
j'ai monté son tilleul à monsieur sa
soeur était avec lui dit de fait vous
venez chercher mon mari hier soir pire
est bavarde et avec lui j'avais le
cafard pourquoi la conversation à terre
était bruyant mots qu elle même si la
forme frais d'études n ont rien ça et ma
mère disait avoir reconnue ma voix jolie
témoignages et lui s'étaient donc
assister à la conversation entre mon
père et pirates nous nos factures tout
en reportant de la torre et vous
pierrette y avez-vous fait après le
départ de luiz parler puis j'ai quitté
mon frère quelques minutes après je suis
défendue par l'escalier de service à ça
je peux le jurer jules mademoiselle
m'embrasser pour la fête de la cuisine
elle ne vous a rien dit en descendant
non vous venu d'hésiter louise
faites attention si la police vous prend
vous pouvez être arrêté comme complicité
c'est grave dans cette vie tranquille ça
n'a pas de sens vous trahissez fier vous
avez dit quelque chose aloyse il ya en
descendant et vous avez peur qu'on la
prenne au mercure et en descendant m'a
donné dix mille fois et m'a demandé de
ne pas parler de sa visite comme ça me
laissait tranquille y apparaît regarde
bien petit grübel dont on permute et 1
s'est pas inscrit vous couchez avec tout
le pays alors du coup seulement toutes
les deux les mêmes
puisque vous mentez pour me faire avoir
des ennuis je vais encore dire pourquoi
m'avez donné dix mille francs
parce que quand je suis entré dans la
chambre de monsieur vous êtes en train
de me dire si tu ne me donnes pas cet
argent je te tiens c'est faux je disais
je me tue à temps
c'est ainsi
et que personne ne bouge jeudi à 6 à huy
nous perdons tout la tête
c'est comme ça dans tous les bons romans
policiers je me connais j'en ai assez ce
court jusqu'au cap frappé une voiture
oui car maintenant il n'y a plus de
doute assassin et camille vous ma poule
e
ça ne peut être qu'une 2007 voilà mon
avis c'est tout
[Musique]
tydos usant tu oublié d'interroger
quelqu'un qui toi moi qui a passé en
revue nos cet emploi du temps d'hier
soir mais tu oublié de nous parler du
tien mais les 2 6 4 une voyons là
seraient descendus du train ce matin
devant mes yeux
erreur comment erreur erreur petite mer
erreur suzon et était hier soir dans la
maison
je les ai vus quand m'as-tu-vu cette
nuit j'ai entrouvert la porte et je t'ai
vu rentrer chez papa il était 4 heures
du matin je n'ai pas tué mon père je
jure suzanne explique toi voyons cette
révélation est bouleversante
oui j'ai pris le train avec elle un jour
avance alors je suis passé par
l'escalier de service
je suis entré chez papa pour lui dire
quelque chose de grave que je voulais
qu'il soit le seul à savoir s'il ne
m'avait pas approuvés jamais je serais
revenu pauvre papa
il a été merveilleux de gentillesse il
m'a promis son appui m'a conseillé de
reprendre le train est de refaire une
station en arrière je lui obéit
je suis parti je suis arrivé ce matin
par le train prévu et que devait-il nous
dire
je vais avoir un enfant parce qu'il ya
la grille est bouclée on ne peut pas
sortir du parc nous sommes enfermés
[Musique]
nous allons vous donner lecture du
bulletin météorologique régional des
chutes de neige persisteront l'année
prochaine sur l'ensemble du territoire
de nombreuses routes sont actuellement
coupé la tempête fait rage sur les côtes
de la manche et de la mer du nord vaut
plusieurs navires sont en perdition
le froid fait de nombreuses victimes et
bien mesdames
ça ne s'arrange pas
[Musique]
2 vous devriez prendre quelque chose
j'ai préparé dans la cuisine un petit
repas froid qu'est ce qu'a mangé auguste
quoi c'est pas parce que nous sommes
coupés du monde tu poses laissé mourir
de faim
moment tu ose me regardez pas ce que tu
as fais toi tu as une autre révélation à
me faire non maintenant j'étais tout dit
une figue
voilà ce que tu es une fille sont des
choses qui arrivent dans votre milieu
sûrement dans le nôtre on se marie avant
pour tarbes et ya plus de milieu à
présent c'est ça le progrès alors je
dois sans doute à féliciter d'attendre
un enfant le fellah dans twin oulouma
sont vos conseils à y venir les cires
sont en train de mourir tu viens d'une
porte de la cuisine l'entouraient de
l'autre c'est tordant en et les gens du
coupé solidaires chiasson passionnés jeu
là vient le poisson mari en tout cas en
ce qui nous concerne ne vous en faites
pas trop le temps arrange tout il la
conduira sans doute pas aux usa est
jolie perspective occupez vous de votre
tri qu'on est pas de ma perspective vue
ouïe poor's
quel fou quelle horreur j'avais lu ça
dans les livres mais jamais jonathan
sait que ça va péter
c'est impossible à croire je t'aime
beaucoup disent et catherine j'ai
beaucoup pensé à toi moi aussi alors
c'est vrai tu vas voir un petit enfant
oui je n'aurais pas dû dire que tu t'es
venu tout à l'heure mais si tu veux bien
c'est comment il a confiance et il est
grand nom avec des yeux faire tel label
qu'est-ce qui fait graves eig dans une
banque la banque et à lui non il est une
bagnole bon ben alors il est fauché mais
tu crois encore que l'argent fait le
bonheur
il a un frère ninon dans ma grosse bête
8 a le temps de penser à ça c'est pas
comment mon âge
toujours le même refrain faut pas lire
il faut pas fumer dans la rue ni lancer
des pierres
ensuite alors que c'est effrayant
les chiens sont n'auront pas fait long
feu mais pourquoi le hamas tué seul but
de va je vais vous le dire - l'assassin
vous le voir si la mort-aux-rats tuer
les gens c'est à présent
attendez vous en mangez dans de brefs
délais donc on gagne et on pas dans quel
état pouces soit disparu et qui a pu
faire ça qui peut nous en vouloir pour
moi voilà moi je peux plus respirer ici
je vais mieux maintenant
à partir de cet instant elle est
interdite de quitter cette pièce je suis
de votre avis si nous nous dispersons
l'assassin frappe une autre fois
pourquoi faire un cauchemar
le téléphone coupé la voiture détraqué
la grille fermée les chiens empoisonnés
vous dirai ce que vous voulez c'est pas
normal
enfin que me conseillez vous de faire on
pourrait peut-être grieg et a volé
quelqu'un sur la foule à travers la
grille avec cette tempête qui s'arrêtera
à tuer dans l'oeuf en gt1 vaga pour ça
ne peut être qu'un vagabond mais non il
faut se rendre à l'évidence c'est une de
vous 7 8 7
je propose que nous restions dans son
salon jusqu'à ce que je dis pas ce que
jusqu'à ce que l'assassin strive jusque
pour avoir une nouvelle victime à
pleurer non non non non réfléchissant
bien on doit trouver quelque chose
ma pauvre petit tu passes ton temps à
réfléchir jusqu'à présent sans résultat
nous savons du moins à quelle heure papa
a été tué à quelle heure après 4 heures
du matin puisque je les quitte à verser
dans la ma charmante façon de vous
placer à nouveau lors du drame
j'ai quitté mon père vivant je voudrais
qu'on me croie oui un bon poids on vous
croit seulement chacune se dit innocente
ya pourtant une coupable entre ses
quatre murs
oui c'est un cercle fermé il n'y a pas
de cercles fermés dans la mécanique
policière parmi nous une manche c'est
l'assassin est ce qu'il est là se cacher
c'est que les autres manteaux si pour
des raisons autres que le meurtre croyez
moi pour découvrir la salsa
il faudra que vous vous découvriez
d'abord en tout cas je préviens la
meurtrière
je suis armé
la prairie y'a que moi aussi quand on
est super c'est la première fois qu'on
voit la balle de revolver nous sommes
perdus je vous dis et vous répète que
nous avons la chance d'être cloîtré et
vous ne voulez pas en profiter tant que
l'assassin est entouré de sept témoins
il ne fera rien on est sept contre un
saut se disperse en est cuite cas vous
avez entendu parler de races qui monte
tranquillement les trois cures yat les a
séparés
tu vois un moment j'ai quand même raté
ça de mes études eh bien ce n'est pas le
moment de jouer les curiaces il se faire
descendre l'une après l'autre
s'il ne nous quitte ce cas tu craques on
est trois mois dans un quart d'heure
écoutez moi
j'ai quelque chose a dit
c'est
avec son coeur il va lui faire une
piqûre même semaine faites bouillir de
l'eau
6 on va chercher sa voix tant que son
talent et son dentier voir des à table
nous manquait plus que ça vient ça
figure ballard année mais louise a
laissé ainsi votre trousse d'infirmières
quoi or non ce repas la piqûre c'est
bien trop bas du scanner pour les
attitudes que drake who is vous ne
pouvez pas refuser débrouillez-vous mais
candidat c'est comme domestiques comme
infirmière sera du service parce que
j'ai bien voulu aujourd'hui je veux plus
de vous ici quitte à ce critère les
piqûres une pompe a refusé c'est
criminel criminel ou pas c'est pareil à
ce serait trop facile on traite comme la
dernière des dernières en accusant
massue tout ça parce que je suis la
femme de son puis tout d'un coup
rafini résoudre mon coeur et que sera
animé - rien à faire face à l'ogre
estime été trop méchant avec moi le
voyez-vous non assistance à une personne
en danger de mort c'est la
correctionnelle et la prison le saviez
vous ces données mais huit jours louise
réfléchissez vous mettez une mauvaise
affaire sur les bras
croyez-moi fait la piqûre conseil d'ami
bon bah si louise mais bien dans la
chambre et la manie de tout déplacer ma
part ski canada
sérieux avant la piqûre est large mais
on sait pas elle est vraiment épanouie
mais le cas d'échec ils ne crient pas
comme ça à 80 mais je me mords les
doigts d'avoir dit en arrivant ici que
j'ai mon diplôme d'infirmier c'est
mademoiselle augustine meurt en route on
dira que c'est mal fait la piqûre a su
propos de meppen russie rentrer ici
jamais fait de me casser une jambe alors
les ampoules sa fin
qu'est ce qu'elle fout non cas très
précis si nous ne trouvons rien trompe
enfin il n'a plus un seul médicament
dans la chambre d'audit
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire on
aurait fait disparaître les médicaments
volontairement map les a peut-être jeter
non on les a ajouté on a voulu tuer
augustine indirectement méfie ailleurs
quelque chose doyon a fallu mettre de
l'eau sur la tête du bol d'or sont
mouillés tiens qui fait là je t'entends
capi qui veut musy flay c'est vraiment
ans est encore en vie tant mieux comment
sens-tu c'est terrible j'ai le coeur
arrêtés n'ont pas douché il pas facile
une piqûre mais on les a été chercher
enfin sont elles dans la table ou
ailleurs dans la table avec les cachets
aussi dans le placard avec tout le reste
tu les a pas changés place n'ont que
l'idée apic une je ne sais pas si ça te
ferait du bien et fait mourir maman mais
non tu vas pas mourir
tut évanoui trois fois par jour ma
petite voix
personne bouge mais il me parle j'ai
compris vous me regarder mourir
vous êtes tous d'accord ça les met ses
crochets comme un chien ah non là on
vous parle vous intégrer au louise mappy
qu on voudra bien ma belle mais tous vos
médicaments ont disparu note me dit
parfait je vais débarrasse la maison je
vais partir comme j'ai vécu tout seul
toujours seul sens coût 100 m avec mon
coeur
tous malades et/ou vide ils nient avec
marcel de propre ici vous l'avez tué
avec votre leader pour moi c'est bien
fini
gordon des anneaux soutien mois
quelle journée je m'en rappellerai cours
avez-vous trouvé les médicaments le val
ne devait pas remonter à plus d'une
heure car augustine qui remontaient dans
sa chambre s'en serait aperçu le voleur
que dis-je la voleuse n'a pas eu plus de
deux ou trois minutes pour accomplir son
geste
elle a donc déposé le paquet où elle a
pu j'ai fouillé les chambres s'étaient
soudain vie lequel le tien moment
souligne sas est un pouce va par exemple
vous la voulez vous remettre sans doute
nos facs qui peut nous en vouloir à ce
point quand c'est un ennemi de la
famille ne sort pas de la baie qui n'est
pas bien fait dit ça c'est quoi le
problème
c'était mal pour moi oui vous avez trop
d'intérêts dans la maison vous ça vous
lie à nous n'a intérêt je vois pas fait
dans l'innocence
vous savez très bien que marcel a pensé
à vous dans son testament il vous l'a
dit vous vous le supposez il me l'a dit
il ya huit jours il m'a dit qu'il
voulait c'est 5 millions ancien mais
c'est une grande nouvelle tu ne disait
rien homme je me souvenais plus que vous
avez dû important qu'on croyait
j'étais si content d'être débarrassé de
vous à ce prix là tiens tiens tiens
marcel hanoun eu un geste il a dû
prendre un rendez vous avec son lot dire
dans les jours qui ont suivi lorsque
vous avez été certain de votre héritage
est en effet différente
marcel n'avait pas encore testé en ma
faveur mais allez le faire
vous avez alors agi de toute urgence
quelle horreur le testament at il été
fait ou non s'il a été fait les soupçons
tonton mois mais s'il ne l'est pas les
soupçons tombe sur vous je peux venir ce
point le testament des paf
à quand j'ai vu papa à l'autre soir il
m'a parlé d'une chose relatives à un
testament
il m'a dit tu as bien fait de me parler
je devais avoir mon notaire dommage
pensera à toi promis hebinger news façon
de dire je n'ai pas tué mon père car le
lendemain ils allaient me couché sur son
testament est ignoble façon de l'accuser
du crime
tu sais que tu es monstrueux suzon de
parler cette façon à ta mère malade et
sont dans l'état où tu es regardons par
fraude car deux mois et on ose me
répéter ce que tu m'as dis jamais jamais
les horreurs j'avais bien joué la scène
du mélodrame pas vous taisez vous hein
du coup plutôt vous étiez et la nuit
dernière c'est pas vous en rendrez
compte mais à la police d'ailleurs une
personne chez qui j'étais pourra
témoigner pour moi un homme sans doute
on m'avait déjà posé la question et je
n'ai pas répondu
c'est vous qui avez aimé les médicaments
sous mon lit pour faire du mal à les
tester ça se voit moins
pourtant
[Musique]
suzan
je vais regarder ce bon lit oui maman
j'ai vu tu as vu jésus tes valises
prêtes garnis bons vieux tu comptais
faire voyage basse et phil ivey piquet
et piquet tu crois qu'on n'est pas une
insolence inquiétante non on s'est fait
des piqûres et tout en mieux c'est une
maman on l'a trouvé les médicaments
souvent lui non qui a pu faire ça se
maintient
puisque nous nous sommes tout balader
dans la maison et luis tu refusais de
faire la piqûre
vous trouvez ça normal ah bah oui quoi
vous lui avez dit des sottises
ceci dit c'est une bien curieuse parce
que j'ai encore faim oui
dites-nous le nom des garçons qui vous
écrivent ici j'ai vu des tas de lettres
dans votre tiroir menteuse vous est
suivi un soir vous mentez mais aussi
tout ce que c'est sûr vous allez c'est
de la discussion jaillit la lumière j'ai
trouvé sous votre matelas des livres
drôlement salée avec des illustrations
pourquoi n'avez vous rien dit on serait
passé mes attributions de se contenter
de les confisquer catherine où as tu
trouvé ses livres je suis par bateau
sortant du collège il était en devanture
d'un kiosque de journaux
c'est une honte ni unique au niveau
c'est luiz qui fouille sous les matelas
les oreilles qu'est mon âge mon iphone
louise fouilles sous les lits elle va
nous dire tout ce qu'elle a vu sur les i
tous les lundis par les louise personne
ne vous punira aussi le syndicat des
gens de maison vous voyez il ancre
aimerais tu voir si personne n'a rien de
précis à reprocher à louise nous ne
pourriez pas la laisser en paix non
moins avec des choses à me reprocher
sans parler de la piqûre qu'elle
refusait de faire un justin je veux dire
que cette fille a ouvert une lettre qui
m'était destinée c'était une erreur une
erreur parfaitement une erreur je suis
obligé de témoigner pour louise c'est
moi qui vais chercher le courrier dans
la boîte depuis dix ans louise
n'approchait jamais elle
rien dérobé c'est ma faute si un jour
j'ai remis une enveloppe de madame
louise envoie la sphère on peut se
tromper la veille d'un mandat dans cette
claque et après on peut se tromper on
peut donner une enveloppe pour une autre
tout le monde peut faire une erreur j'en
fais souvent mois deux erreurs tenez un
jour j'ai surpris madame votre grand
mère en train de boire au goulot d'une
bouteille de porto
eh bien c'était une erreur elle ne l'a
bien expliqué elle regardait dedans pour
la cie la bouteille est évident et je ne
suis pas allé raconter partout que c'est
une fois bravo madame chanel puisque
vous êtes cionet vous allez nous
expliquer pourquoi alors que vous avez
dit être parti de la maison vers minuit
pourquoi et votre manteau et votre fils
eut accroché dans le vestibule de nos
fils et cela vers 1h30
quand je suis venu chercher valais nous
allons vous avez la répartie facile
répondez répondait non
oui je suis revenue dans la maison vers
1h du mat
ah ah oui je suis foutu dans la maison
vers une heure du matin à quoi elle
n'avait il pas dit je ne sais pas moi je
pensais pas qu'on en arriverait là je
croyais qu'on allait arrêter la coupable
tout de suite pourquoi tu éprouvé le
besoin de revenir après minuit en
quittant la maison je suis rentré
directement à monta billon vous avez
laissé pierrette il était la pudeur du
soin et le contenu offert une partie de
cas quand je n'ai trouvé personne chez
moi j'avoue que j'ai eu peur peur enfin
non ce n'est pas le mot je veux dire que
j'ai pensé qu on s'était croisés et que
pierrette avait dû venir voir monsieur
et je craignais le rencontrent leurs
différents leur dispute
bravo jeune ben vous fait du beau
travail
dites plutôt que vous êtes revenu par
besoin par besoin de jouer ça vous tient
la passion du poker si vous voulez
insinuer youn est donc monté chez papa
vers 1h oui les tuyères trouver
pierrette oui petit fils
rien rien comment rien que faisait-il et
bien il joue et où qu'à l'arrêt ce que
vous dites mon mari soit aux cartes
aussi oui madame depuis quand
depuis ne put de vue mon arrivée ici
sans doute oui c'est faux marcel cours
et les tripots à tous c'est vrai j'avais
paris je peux vous en parler en
connaissance de cause et moi qu'il
pilotait alors on vient de fameux colis
tous ses défauts sur mon compte et vous
c'est sans doute depuis mon arrivée ici
que vous avez cette passion du jeu
duperré et c'est un marseillais vous
étiez deux innocents sans doute à qui
j'ai passé la paix au nom moi je joue
depuis toujours
seulement depuis votre arrivée
je perds plus souvent c'est tout mais
vous avez englouti toutes vos économies
maintenant vous allez dire que je triche
et vous vole on ne dit rien parce que eh
bien parce que quoi parce que je n'ai
pas de preuves on ne l'a pas de points
vont peut-être
j'avais deux à stocker
ma chanel toi provost suzon je te jure
que je suis incapable d'avoir fait
quelque chose de mal ne crois pas ça ou
à ma petite fille mais alors si je
comprends bien
marcel pierrel du paname chanel il
jouait aux cartes au moment des pointes
ou l'effroi tu regrettes ne pas avoir
fait le 4e pont j'ai été tiré salam
channel vous qui aviez toute ma
confiance
vous l'accusez décès l'honneur d'élever
mes filles allaient bien que j'ai eu
l'honneur de les élever madame parce que
si elle n'avait tu vaux attention il
n'aurait pas eu grand chose
c'est la première et la dernière fois
que j'entends de paris propos madame
chanel quand la police arrive pas je ne
vous épargnerai pas comme vous voudrez
madame n'ai rien à cacher moi chanel as
tu joué longtemps au poker avec papa et
pierre à thiers sports wii plus d'une
heure
tu as gagné perdu on va faire du bien ça
nous convient car je suppose que vous ne
jouez pas pour rien
combien trois cent mille âmes j'ai payé
non j'ai reporté à qui
l'équité vivant jamais j'aurais pu faire
une horreur pareille je suis sorti en
naissant parce que mes pierrette
continuer la partie des mesures qui
reste vous êtes donc resté seul avec mon
père qu'avez vous fait rien rien c'est
pas vrai je me suis entendu vous avez ri
de moi vous avez ri parce que vous aviez
très fier tous les deux vous avez aimé
parce que vous m'aviez voyez 300 mille
francs au plat quand vous venez de vous
trahir le doute n'est plus possible
c'est vous qui avait tué marcelle j'ai
ma conscience pour moi je ne me suis pas
retiré en province pour me garer d'une
mauvaise affaire ouah chanel tu les as
entendu rive alors qu'est ce que tu as
fait tu viens j'ai pleuré
en fait on classe tranquille
c'est donc vous pire est maintenant qu
est la dernière à avoir vu mon père
vivant non louise a dû le voir plus tard
et de plus près pourquoi voulez vous ce
soir montus voir monsieur c'est de la
calomnie
marcel et ses deux filles se
connaissaient depuis cinq ans qu'est ce
que vous dites c'est un corps de
garçonnière de week-end clandestins
l'hiver dernier dans la place de femme
de chambre si elle est libre lui s'est
fait engager
c'est ce qu'on appelle s'installer à
domicile leurs yeux mieux de vous
occuper de vos affaires sont déjà assez
mal en point louise
que devons nous penser que ce que nous
voulons entendre
vous connaissiez messieurs avant vous
avez accepté d'un commun accord de faire
la femme de chambre oui si vous avez
accepté cette corvée facilement oui
pourquoi
epages en entendre belle
pas besoin d'écouter aux portes voulu
râler comment te sens-tu augustine suis
pas encore enterré pas joli joli tout ça
or marcel il était bien à plaindre avec
vous.tout il aurait volontiers console
aimé sport c'est ça j'aime ta colère
sûrement pour masquer le fait que
surpris marcel et louise ensemble et
plus tard tu t'es venger dans la nuit tu
oses dire sa jolie tes filles merci
catherine et la méchanceté la paresse
réuni ses romans lus en tourner la tête
chaque fois donné que le midget quelques
médisance sur moi et suzon va avoir un
enfant
bravo à toi de juger nvidia mois suzon
est enceinte
quand je pense qu'elle nous a interrogés
comme la justice des séductions centre
de mon temps on respectait les jeunes
filles parce qu'elle se respecte est
maintenant elles vont au cinéma au
drugstore
elle fut porte des pantalons font du
camping sans faire des enfants pas tant
pis pour elle la négligence dans
l'éducation des filles portent ses
fruits puisque tout ceci bien élever les
enfants
pourquoi dans le dip ont fait une
douzaine on m'a respectée
hu est respecté mais quel résultat
elle ne mérite pas vu à fait bien si les
chocs mais moi je suis bien qu'elle mais
c'est à dire du tout que la première qui
attaquent encore du stif c'est à moi
qu'elle aura à faire et essieux moment
une cogneuse une ingrate
j'aurais dû te laisser croupir ou après
demain soir là là c'est un très fort il
se cache derrière nos défauts nos
faiblesses nos mensonges joli tableau de
famille la petite catherine j'aurais
tout donné au monde pour qu'ils ne
soient pas là aujourd'hui
tu sais je ne dépare pas l'eau et si
nous reprenions la conversation au
moment où tentes augustine c'était
valleuse je disais quand le dispersant
l'assassin comme race pouvait frapper
nous nous sommes dispersés los camins
qu'on a eu lieu au camer on a encore eu
lieu donc il est en marche n'a pas tout
à fait tort façon de vivre dans la
terreur de sa voisine est intolérable
moi à ta place saint-augustin jeu sera
une quête
l'assassin a dérobé des ampoules les a
mal cachés comme s'il voulait qu'on les
retrouve vite et tu t'es quand même se
piquer avec les courageux 20 l'ampoulé
que tu attaques
tu n'es pas dit que vous aviez vie du
poison dans la stricte at elle dit pour
ta j'aurais nous rendre folle non tu te
permets n'ont pu suivre âge j'ai
l'impression les piqûres me font pas le
même effet que d'habitude
tactique une ampoule toi aussi tu es toi
c'est le champagne a éclaté
on avait éteint la flamme de la
veilleuse j'ai voulu râlant mais tout a
explosé au l'ophite pour toujours dire
que comme vous donnez moi des chiffons
début juin toyota le plus avec le cacha
dans ce coin s'est montré solide mais
c'est mon action qui se dit encore plein
temps qui veut nourrir à mais je me dis
oui mais il perd 4 éthiques
tu peux laisser quinze hôtesses qui ne
vaut plus rien j'en connais qui me
ferait fin et les louis d'or peut pas
aimer l'argent c'est effrayant
ça fait deux heures qu'on n'a pas
entendu une parole sensée dame madame
j'ai compris j'ai tout compris
parce que vous avez compris oui tout
compris enfin presque pas parlé il ne me
manque plus qu'une dernière preuve
[Musique]
vous allez tout rester là sans bouger
les sortir par la terrasse pour vérifier
quelque chose accordez-moi quelques
minutes je vous rapporte la vérité sur
la mort de monsieur nous tuer ce pauvre
vous croyez à ce qu'elles racontent sans
aucun doute elle sait quelque chose elle
divague duo est elle partie est
simplement remarquer que personne ne
devait sortir et que vous avez laissé
faire
c'est vrai elle nous échappe ce serait
évidemment et c'est le nom de l'assassin
oui bah je crois que je cherche à nous
compromettre alors qu'à sauter sur
toulouse en vient à kashan où vivait
oussama compagnie c'était bien ça je
sais tout
où sont elles pourquoi sont-elles partie
où êtes vous oui trou
même celle de mon dieu elle est morte
parce qu'elle savait en tout cas
maintenant nous sommes sur blessure de
quoi l'assassin c'est pareil
[Musique]
entre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voix
une panne maintenance à rostock
oh
tu voues louise c'est vraiment celle que
steve a eue
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pas soit la
marche pas c'est trop tard
elle voit qu'à lui faire toucher les
fils à court circuit ce que je suis mais
moi ce que je joue mieux sera mauvais
mais un petit pot de café à nous
remonter besoin
[Musique]
louise vous fumez non mais vous ont
rempli
est ce que vous voyez que ce bois
mon coeur qu'est ce qu'elles font non à
l'oser channel sur lui elle a pris
connaissance
oui elle parle pas la panne n'a même pas
touché
et bien la peine pas heureusement robot
1 à wil heureusement
la matière est sûre vous aurez plus
émouvoir bien l'assassin à la pâte et
vouloir tout chanel les enfants ou alors
il est drôlement bien raté une cible
pareil c'est invraisemblable non non
l'assassin du vouloir impressionner
chanel un ultimatum
une invitation au silence la preuve
chanel se taire en tout cas moi si
j'apprends quelque chose
j'avais aussi ma vie n'est pas
merveilleuses mais j'y tiens tous ces
éléments auront au moins appris à vivre
moi je réfléchisse si chanel pas on la
supprime c'est la loi vous lisez dans
pas les journaux plus bas à témoin
gênant ça su communiquer avec un aplomb
ah oui oui c'est drôle je suis plus dur
que vous toutes et je fais travailler ma
tête il faut que je sache vous avez une
idée vase et une malheureusement mais
vain
[Musique]
vous soupçonnez de vous deux en plus ça
ne perçoivent bien sûr charmante enfant
va juillet qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire nous avons tous besoin de faire
quelque chose là ça c'est surtout ça
doit produire un drôle de choc de tir au
revolver vous savez déjà tirez-vous
hannon et toi quand tu seras envoie une
question d'une vente avec un jour j'ai
failli à la fois pas tirer sur des
fleurs j'ai une demande est passée la
donbass et la carabine il a refusé
il n'était pas toujours gentil papa et
puis toujours le même refrain tue trop
petit ou trop petits fz8 mots mes 20 ans
non si je devais passer maintenant je
peux faire tout ce que je fais là car
secret regardez le porto de grand mère
n'ont pas pu goûter à l'or
[Musique]
ben moi
et
vous êtes une brasserie luis bon j'ai
pas fait un peu brusque avec
mademoiselle il faut pas m'en vouloir je
vous en de d'autant moins que je sais
très bien que je suis là vraiment non
mais s'il ya un monstre je suis à tuer
tuer ceux qui m'aiment encore un malheur
je sens la mort qui rôde
j'ai peur car à non vous savez par aussi
l'aï commencé pour ça que le cloud
écoutez bien ceci il faut que je sache
dans un quart d'heure ou plus tard le
nom de la csn patins et quand je serai
qui sait je l'exécutera moi tout seul
sans l'aide de personne vous dit pas ça
si je le dis avec moi pas de police je
règle mes affaires sans intermédiaire
vous avez des soupçons réel oui
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour vous
aider
aller me chercher le sucrier le sud fait
ça des petits copains les corbeaux et
corbeaux les corbeaux c'est pas un petit
copain
qu'est ce que tu lui a raconté
oriane grave j'ai voulu un pull à
secouer j'ai l'impression d'avoir
vieilli 10 ans en une journée
moi aussi c'est bon comment c'est bon
d'être une femme et non pas une petite
fille qu'on ne croit pas au sérieux
on vous écoute on avait peur de ce que
vous dites on ne vous répète plus reste
là ce n'est pas ton âge tu ne pouvait
quand même pas venir avec nous coucher
chanal regardent sans rien dire
avec deux droitiers pourquoi ne parlent
pas ou bien elle ne peut pas parler ou
bien elle ne veut pas elle couvre
qu'elles captent impossible il ya six
ans tu as déjà tiré au revolver en
laisse moto à part on dirait que tu
voudrais éviter de parler de ça il faut
pourtant que la vérité se fasse tu as
peur de la vérité me catherine vont bâti
atr point tasse de café ça te remettra
un rendement une catherine moi je peux
pas rester tout seul ça c'est pas pour
supplier jésus du café louise maillot la
cuisine
maintenant je file dans ma chambre et je
me bats ricard de l'avoir devant l
assassin peut-être un mois ou deux
avec ménez
bénévolat
l'essai chanel on peut pas lui tirer
amours mes enfants elle semble effondré
la mort partout mais ne suffit donc pas
comme si ça n'allait pas je ne sais pas
non plus elle est présentée avec vous
non pourvu que ce soit pas parti parti
nous a échappé je vous ai dit vingt fois
que cette femme était dangereuse on m'a
pas écouté elle a pas répondu à une
seule de mes questions qu'at-elle fait
hier soir alors là mystère on s'embête
pas ici et maintenant baledent lui
courir après marester pour l'humilier
mais bien que se passe-t-il venant fait
détecte dans une pierre est a pris la
clé des champs
comment ça va les parties allaient
sûrement pas loin la grille est bouclé
et quant à sauter nous il ya de quoi ce
quasi coup on avait cent tandis que
personne ne devait sortir dans nos amis
aux oreilles ça donne un peu plus que
les affaires de pierrette sont encore là
ah oui son sac et bafouillent leur nom
tient suzon vas-y toi
qui avait raison
je pense à toutes les accusations j'ai
dû subir ou la soutane ya tout contre
moi
enfin papa c'est fini je respirais
j'avais tellement peur ce fut l'une de
nous tue c'est gaby au fond je ne
pensais pas toutes les choses que je
t'ai dit écoutez voilà ce qui a pu se
passer
pierrette s'est disputée hier soir avec
marcelle puy allait rentrer
tranquillement se coucher dans le
pavillon chez chanel à l'onb l heure est
venue tué marcelle et au lieu de rentrer
chez elle comme elle nous l'a dit eh ben
elle a attendu patiemment le moment de
faire sa réapparition ici prétextant un
mystérieux coup de téléphone tu crois
étant dans la place elle a mis de la
mort aura dans l'assiette des chiens
info les revolver a voulu supprimer ou
enfin intimider son ami chanel qui en
sait trop mais parfois la home et tout
s'éclaire mes enfants tout s'enchaîne
louise porter vite l'état c'est tout le
monde se met à sa recherche a les
meilleures feuilles walf tv
je me rappelle maintenant j'ai vu me
sentirai dans la cuisine avec une sauce
au vol et cession de kkr sommes pas
sonné il m'a collé plus d'autant
aller chercher d'une lettre du père m'a
plu tout moment cette patience et les
mots de nos enfants
[Musique]
est ce que c'est que ce bruit bien trop
bien ça il faut des vols vas-y katrina
n'oubliez pas que c'est pas le moment de
faire des bêtises et que nous n'avons
que des doutes sur pirates ils sont
fondés sur le fait qu'elle est partie ce
n'est pas partisan après tout ce que je
t'ai dit il accroît encore innocent
blois te mens tu en a trop dit quoi
revolver dans son sac mais l'a7 5km
après avoir tiré sur madame chanel et le
café
pour le moment nous sommes toutes
vivantes non qu'est ce qu'on fait alors
eh bien d'abord le fait disparaître dans
un bonne marche
ensuite nous nous essayons calmement
ils le feront du café tient aux phillies
cette année et ben moi je pourrais pas
rester calme je sors reste deux mamans
cette veste kaki fait c'est impossible
de tuer quelqu'un comme ça tu t'en
répondant pas pris les toits de mettre
en danger at eu le courage de lui parler
toi suzon je vais essayer a tancé la cia
vous
où étiez-vous pierrette
dans la salle de bains mme allan
mais oui chanel où l'avez-vous mise sur
le lit de maman elle a parlé
rassurez-vous n'a rien dit vous les
faits tout casser
vous laisse ou ducasse et non merci
je suis déjà tourné un peu et rhett
buvait dont sept tasses de café moi j'en
bois jamais un buffet ce qu'a fait et
pourquoi tenez vous tant le faire boire
pas tenez vous tant vous à ne pas le
voir j'ai compris êtes tout complices
avaient assassiné mon frère maintenant
vous voulez me supprimer comme vous avez
essayé de supprimer chanel
enfin pourquoi voulez-vous me tuer mais
nous ne voulons pas vous tuer vous êtes
la seule à ne pas avoir bu de café avec
tenez regardez toutes nos tasses sont
vides
nous pensions vous étiez parti est
présent dans le café mois et ben alors
prouvez nous le contraire ont longuement
souvent dans la bulle en boire sans
crainte
louise n'a pas vu non plus celle cuisine
à 3
vous allez reparti ci devant nous tout
moment alors vous n'avez pas bu tout
vous avions oublié lui il va oublier
alors vous allez envoyer à la mort
pourrait n'oublie pas la vôtre
et louise buvait
enfin qu'est ce que vous attendez je
croiserai quand elle a rappelé ses peurs
j'ai proposé un café j'ai eu peur de
mourir s'asseoir et enfin je suis pas
sorti de la salle de bains enfants dans
la cuisine vous aurez tout sur la
cafetière et vous vous avez fait le café
alors c'est pille on leur fait part de
force à tous les déracinés de dire des
sottises
alors vous le pv ce qu'a fait je refuse
alors tant pire est bon ce n'est pas
tout les deux amphores catherine
pourquoi elle n'avait pas laissé
personne mais je les laissais boire
salle là qu'est ce que tu as fait pas
mourir mais sérieusement c'est bien la
tan tan m
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait non je l'avais
la cité à lutter sans merci
la voilà comme quand on s'attaque à quoi
au comment vous sentez-vous en ça va ça
va je me demande pour quelle raison vous
êtes tous ligués contre moi la raison la
voici ce revolver trouver dans votre sac
non il ya me brillon je le jure
évidemment d'ailleurs ce sera facile à
prouver quand la police examinera le
verra bien qui a pas mais en pointe
toni vous vous l'avez tout tripoter tu
veux pas penser à ça
là ça ça nous isole pour nous empêcher
de prévenir la police il faut sortir de
cette maison c'est une question de vie
ou de mort huit le portail est fermé
façon partout sur mon nom les secteurs
minier s'est montré fier mais ça m'a pas
mal commis sur la terre est ce drame m'a
tuer je n'ai plus qu'à me tairai
maintenant dans ma petite ville on est
une jolie petite ville est ce que vous
dites je suis rien
votre sourire et bavard on a dit
beaucoup de choses sur vos souris en mai
qu'il soit bavard jamais et puisque nous
sommes seuls toutes les deux mythes moi
merci et n'en parlons plus merci de quoi
avoir plus ma langue et que le propos à
quel propos je vous ai vu souvent de
loin et je vous envie y ait de quoi vous
pouvoir jouer sur les deux tableaux
jamais eu talent pour les devinettes
vous avez un amant j'ai eu un amant
alors ça c'est votre dernière trouvaille
non ma première mais je ne sais depuis
longtemps
trois bandits j'ai tué mon mari parce
que j'ai un hammam un nom je police
c'est toutes les femmes qui ont un amant
tuer leur mari aurait pas beaucoup
d'amants sur la terre ni de mari ce sont
les mêmes alors et après si j'ai un
amant qu'est-ce que ça prouve
voilà bien avancés on vous croira corps
j'ai jamais eu l'intention de le dire
mais enfin quel but poursuivent et vous
au gain je sais que vous avez un amant
c'est tout alors oui je vois c'est du
chantage nom de là
curiosité enfin si c'est moi l'assassin
vous ne pensez pas que votre curiosité
comme celle de chanel pourrait vous
jouer un vilain tour en allant prendre
un risque pour rageuse
non non je re général comment un homme
petit osé mais croyez sans doute plus
désirable que moi vous savez le désir
chez un homme c'est bien souvent qu'un
vice compulsive
il doit vous pensez pas que nous nous
égarons à la laci toutes les femmes se
serrer les coudes elle mènerait le monde
pour de bon car nous croyons le menu ce
sont les hommes que nous entretiennent
dans cette illusion mais entre eux ils
sont d'accord croyez moi les hommes vous
en dons faites en mal oui même marcel
surtout marcel malfait pour les autres
roms je m'en fiche
le rendu est bien seul parent qui me
restait c'était mon frère quand je suis
revenu ici là été lâche m'a fermé sa
porte au nez et renvoyé à mes aventures
massage n'oublierai jamais alors pour
l'embêter
je vais obligé à me recevoir la nuit à
me donner de l'argent louisa bien
entendu si qu'il ne donne pas cet argent
je te tue bah quand on a une soeur qui
est dans la mouise et qu'on est pas se
relever ça se paye le dit dans tout ce
que vous dites vous accuse
ou tu pas lara chalet ni vous ni moi
alors vous me croyez innocentes ont
certainement écouté pierrette je
voudrais vous remercier pour votre
discrétion bon port pour moi bien sûr
pour mes filles côté puisque vous me
fait confiance je vais vous avouer
quelque chose de pire malaisie
je devrais être loin à l'heure qu'il est
je quittais mon mari ce soir mes valises
étaient prêtes
quoi qu'est marseille comment il croit
on mari assassiné la nuit où je le
quitte
c'est atroce mais marcel se douter de
quelque chose sûrement pas toujours tout
gober alors maintenant qu'est ce que je
vais devenir moi j'ai voté pierrette cet
argent marcel vous a refusé
ben je vous le donnerai mon arrivée j'ai
mon team l'a pas refuser comment il
voulait mais pourquoi n'en avoir rien
dit s'il vous la donner je pourrais pas
le prouver je vais plus mais qu'est ce
que vous en avez fait je vais donner un
homme que j'aime donner ouais bah je
paye aussi qu'une ou deux fois moins ça
m'arrive on avait besoin de cet argent
pour un voyage voyage
combien marcel vous at il donné il me
fallait et 800 mille balles huit cent
mille francs ils voulaient a donné ce
que vous avez pirette qui est cet homme
à qui vous avez donné cet argent des
devises mais enfin pour les watts de
quoi avez vous peur cet argent était
effet dans une enveloppe non possible ça
vous n'allez pas dire que mais qui est
votre amant comment vous ne le savez pas
non c'est l'associé de mon mari jean
louis jacques fouroux jacques votre
amant c'est mon enveloppe ça c'est mon
argent mais c'est l'argent marseille
déjà vous a donné et ben l'enveloppé
vide l'argent n'y est plus
quelqu'un savait
[Musique]
dégoûté votre air tranquille de femmes
bien nourris bien soigné sans peur du
lendemain 1
on peut tout se dire maintenant je suis
une bourgeoise ratés comme vous vous
êtes une [ __ ] je vous dirais tu serais
fier d'une seconde supprimer moi comme
vous avez supprimé mais rien non rien
l'échelle est ce qu'on a pu sortir midi
saint michel est positif de sortie à
visiter franchir le mur puis les trouble
fêtes la neige lorsque vous tombez notre
coup de jeune en peut plus mais il faut
faire quelque chose et vous tu aller
chercher la folie la police tout le
monde en parle en faisant virer chaque
et la peur de la voir arriver
l'assassin doit bien rire et s'il n'y
avait pas d' assassin parminou quoi si
l'assassin n'était pas l'une de nous
cette y avez-vous pensé
si la csn papa n'était pas si si une
personne n'a pu entrer ni sortir et si
la sason papa était si c'était chan chan
mais qui alors aurait tiré sur elle mais
personne elle même
imaginez la scène nous sommes tous
dispersés
elle revient voit que les sols oui vous
avez vous l avenue dans le bol d'air
alors elles tirent en l'air pour elle
cache le plus tard dans le stade de
temps de pirates qui se trouve la
puisade dos en faisant la morte elle n'a
plus qu'à attendre pour second but et
fun temporairement que tu as eu le plein
porte mais rejetant le couloir d'à nous
apparaître
histoire de nous faire mourir de porc
regardait la voilà
vous avez meilleure solution de proposer
non catherine est ce qu'il y à toujours
dans la sphère de huisseau un passage
que le chien apple il doit y être encore
je vais fort je vais essayer de passer
le moment si elle arrive à sortir nous
sommes sauvés mais voudra-t-elle sorti
je me méfie des initiatives de chacune à
présent je la suis ne bougez pas content
tu me déguise on fait la cuisine
celui-ci est rempli si l'année par lula
pagny ans quand je vous entends ça vous
croyez que il vaut mieux ne pas nous
séparer à moins que je ne suis pas
satisfait mettez plutôt rassurante c'est
ce que dit catherine est effrayante
c'est elle qui découvrira l'assassin
vous lirez batman est doux et
respectueux j'ai tout compris
je sais je sais pas moi comme une flèche
il vint caf une découverte
sensationnelle mais elle est elle-même
entraîne ses couverts électriques etc
qui est coupable quand j'étais étudiante
elle massive du sort de madame dynamo
kiev était moins bien marquer je sais
que je vais y avoir un malheur quatrième
essai paru bien maman
je
voleuse profite de ses derniers instants
de liberté
tu as perdu ta prins était coupable tu
vas passer le reste était jours en
prison tu ne reverras jamais ton amant
nous pu effacer couteau par trois larges
angles semblerait enfin la salle volos
tu m'en veux tu me fais payer ta vie
ratée à celle annoncée par catherine
montus m'ont dit mais qu'est ce que vous
faites vous disputez encore catherine
est en danger de mort ces gars le moment
mon dieu mon dieu faites que cette
conduite est très long elle est morte
regardez ce permet à côté d'elle alors
que catherine a donc été suivi d'une
frappe et rapide chéri et 7e rappelé dit
quitte à frapper mandela oui elle a dû
trouver le passage dans l'est dis-moi tu
veux qu'elle fait à ma chérie mais enfin
quitte à frapper veut pas dire que six
hauts cantons les filles mères on est
capable de tout
comptez tout à fait clair dans le
meurtre de la fais les choses qui est
flagrant
pourquoi ce crime abominable avec son
couteau on aurait pu empoisonner marcel
tranquillement sans risque sans danger
non dont quelques uns étaient là par
hasard
il agit vite comme la plus forte plus
approchant marcel règlement tout sauf
une la visite imprévue
suzon cuzon sinon c'est pas possible on
crie sa colère contre son père ne
voulait pas même pas de bus des tra
bénédiction ne va pas je serai suivre ma
petite fille croisée vous n'êtes pas
réellement talent et à la police mais
n'ira pas il va lui dire n'importe quoi
quelques passages des chiens est bouché
le passage des chiens est bouché mon ami
de fil de fer barbelé
vous avez trouvé quelque chose oui la
boîte de mort aux rats dans ton armoire
c'est toi qui lis à trouver oui et alors
je te regarde tu n'es plus de visage qui
m'étaient familiers
c'est terrible il me semble que je
vienne te perdre toi aussi tu as bien
failli perdre en effet la prochaine fois
de plus fort mais d'un monstre et
puisque tu m'accuses moi aussi je vais
dire ce que j'ai découvert accroché au
fil de fer barbelé il y avait un morceau
des tofs l'assassin avait laissé deux
pièces à conviction
la voici c'est un morceau de thon
peignoir catherine
que penses tu de ma trouvaille elle vous
la mienne rassure toi
la police ne va pas tarder à arriver
j'écris ya une voiture qui passait sur
la route d'alerter les gendarmes ne
seront pas donc de toutes façons à
présent les dés sont jetés
c'est l'une de nous deux
mais le chien des obama
s'ils sont vivants mais je suis soit les
regarder mais il fallait bien vous lever
voyons c'est imprudent
il fallait que je descende ici il
fallait que je peins doucement mais
parlez nous vous écoutons
c'est une drôle d'histoire
catherine ma petite fille bien fait de
moi
tu sais tout chaleur n'est ce pas
oui donc la police est avertie peut-être
pourrions-nous savoir ce que signifie
tous ses mystères à l'écart
alors écoutez moi un beau conte de noël
il était une fois brave homme qui était
entouré de huit femmes il luttait lutin
lutin mais elles étaient les plus fortes
hier soir ce pauvre homme s'est couché
encore plus fatigué plus ruinés plus
tromper que la veille et la ronde de
séries femme a recommencé et sa fille
catherine cacher derrière la porte à
tout vu et tout entendu
et voici ce qui se passe à dix premiers
tableaux sa belle mère qui l'a
recueillie chez lui lui refuse ces
titres une générosité peut sauver cet
homme mais la vieille et à baa1 10h30
deuxième tableau
augustine la vipère de services va faire
sa cour et baver les derniers potins
tente n'a pas tué papa elle l'a écoeuré
sans plus
mais tout cela n'est pas sérieux à 11h
le fond s'il commence sa femme ma mère
il fait comprendre que nous quitte
elle part avec l'homme qui a ruiné
soumare et allez donc comme c'est sa
house rémy louis yves fait son entrée
devant pauvres idiots vulgaires et
intéressait peu après voici pierrette
elle viendrait à la vache à lait huit
cent mille fois bonne chance mais les
billets ne vont pas loin mais ceci est
une autre histoire
pour couronner le tout suis sa fille
clandestinement arrivée de londres lui
annonce qu'elle est enceinte
sur ce bonne nuit qui m'apparaissent at
il ensuite
there is the quest ou l'écouté
vous ne faites plus que ça maintenant
pour vous c'est terminé il ne reste plus
que moi et toi c'est toi pourquoi pas de
les retrouver à 6 heures ce matin
il pleurait c'est terrible à papa qui
pleure vous n'en avez jamais vu son nez
avec une grosse larme au bout il m'a dit
tu une gentille petite fille tu ne te
lave pas les mains tu lis trop mais je
n'ai plus que tout au monde
non j'ai juré de faire son bonheur à
tout prix il pleurait toujours il a dit
comme on doit être bien quand on est
mort alors j'ai eu pitié pitié pitié ses
grands yeux ouverts toureau tout mouillé
alors j'ai unités
l'idée de le libérer catherine ne veut
pas dire que c'est toi qui aurait deux
qui auraient tué papa mais qui parle de
tuer mais papa laisse jamais d'emma et
c'était ça la force à voir et ce qui me
permettait de vous juger avec humour
papa n'a jamais été mort il est mort
derrière ça plein appui non non ne
pleure plus les dames de la famille n'en
valent pas la peine
écoute je vais organiser une
représentation haute aux bénéfices est
ce que tu as vu joué le malade
imaginaire
non et bien dans le malade imaginaire le
type de mort pour savoir ce que pense sa
femme sa fille et toute la maison alors
regard tu talons sur ton lit je colle se
coupa prigent poignard dans le dos ton
pyjama je reverse de l'anc au rouge
partout pauvre papa
il m'a regardé d'un drôle d'air comme
s'il faisait ma connaissance
et puis s'est mis à rire karim mari ça
lui a fait du bien de rire
alors je lui dis elles vont toutes
crever père à ça je te jure alors j'ai
remonté contre vous une énorme comédie
macabre s'est téléphoné à pire elle
coupé les fils du téléphone a dormi les
chiottes traquer la voiture voilà les
huit cent mille fois le revolver de pape
a subtilisé la clé de la chambre de papa
pour qu'on lui fiche la paix bref j'ai
tout réglé tout prévu même un attentat
contre moi et vous avez marché
il
chanel qui soudain ya soupçon qui a vu
papa derrière sa fenêtre c'est ça or
j'ai dit de faire peur excuse moi ma
grosse mais il fallait que tu pèses que
j'aille jusqu'au bout que tout les
mérites éclate
oui depuis ce matin à papa bien vivant
derrière sa porte
n'ayant pas perdu un mot de tout ce que
vous avez dit papa enfin libéré de vous
tout attend que sa petite catherine
l'appel pour que de partir loin très
loin tous les deux tu en as et entendu
papa tu es convaincu alors j'arrive la
clé des champs nous ne pourrons pas tort
ce
cette fois
c'est vraiment vous qui l'avez tué
bah
la pièce que nous venons de représenter
devant vous prix du quai des orfèvres
1961 est de robert thomas
la mise en scène et de jean le poulain
le décor de roger hart
les robes sont de donald cowell
la réalisation sonore et de forêts
kirilov
avec corinne le poulain
mad men barbus les
plongez mia
[Musique]
zach mills et fort
mony dalmès
nadia barentin
et bernadette robert
clerval
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]